when the soccer world cup kicks off this
Thursday imagine watching it as 3d
holograms on your kitchen table that may
not be far off thanks to a new technique
that turns YouTube videos into 3d
reconstructions of matches the key to
the approach is a convolutional neural
network a type of artificial
intelligence algorithm loosely modeled
on the part of the brain that processes
visual data that researchers trained to
estimate how far the surfaces of each
player are from the camera that recorded
the match the network analyzed 12,000 2d
images of players extracted from the
soccer video game FIFA alongside the
corresponding 3d data from the game
engine to learn how the two correlate
that allowed it to estimate depth maps
for players from unseen 2d images when
shown unseen videos the system
accurately predicted depth maps for each
player and combine them with the color
footage to reconstruct each player in 3d
the players were then superimposed on a
virtual soccer pitch allowing the match
to be viewed in any 3d content viewer
the researchers tested the approach with
microsoft's hololens smart glasses which
let them overlay the 3d reconstruction
onto a real-world tabletop the end
product is still glitchy and can't
recreate the ball doesn't work in real
time and only permits watching from the
side of the pitch the video was recorded
but the technique could be more scalable
than leading approaches for
reconstructing sport and 3d which
require arrays of cameras around the
pitch recording every angle the
researchers say the approach should also
work for other events that happen in
predefined arenas like music concerts or
theater
[Music]
you